I was at what was I gonna say though I
was gonna say something about the
[ __ ] I was at the [ __ ] coffee bean
oh no I got my car washed is what it was
and I just got my car wash in one fire
and I even get rid of was waiting for me
to get back because I was getting my car
washed and I was just sat there and look
here's the deal when you get your car
wash get your car washed you get your
car wash that's it that's what you get
the job you get on your car wash is the
job you got on your car wash okay when
the guy swings the towel around and goes
hey you're done you go up you give them
the [ __ ] tip you get in your car you
get the [ __ ] out of there you know what
you don't do a once-over dude you don't
look this is something if you're a dude
you do this you're a [ __ ] and if you're
a girl you do this you're a
[ __ ] diva dude when you see I
saw this woman there with a red dress on
with a red [ __ ] Sunday dress on just
pointing at spots that weren't clean and
the guy was like okay and he was just
and dude she look if you leave a [ __ ] if
you say oh you forgot to do the tires I
hear for the tires okay
but this girl was like there's a spot
there there's a spot over there there's
a spot over there dude and the guy was
just like what if I worked at the carpet
dude I would be fired immediately
there's a spot there I get the one spot
she said oh there's a spot over there I
say oh really okay I get another spot
and then the third spot she said there's
a spot over there I'd look at her and
I'd say go [ __ ] yourself you're not
gonna Beverly Hills me baby you're not
gonna Beverly Hills me man you don't
bring that [ __ ] you know what keep that
[ __ ] in Beverly Hills how about that
we're in [ __ ] West Hollywood [ __ ]
that you keep that Beverly Hills [ __ ] in
Beverly Hills man it goes as far as
bel-air and that's it you bring that
[ __ ] down - WeHo go [ __ ] yourself